Today, I'm teaching my brother how to
actually read the charts like a trader
and start to take trades with just $4.
If you follow along, you'll learn things
about the market that took me years to
truly understand. And it's what
separates profitable traders from
everyone else. We're breaking down
advanced chart patterns and how to read
the signals in the market and the exact
five-step checklist I use to profit from
these signals. We're building a simple
repeatable plan to profitably approach
the market every day, even as a
beginner. So, let's get you and my
brother reading the markets like you've
been doing it for years. Okay, so week
two, we are trying to start focusing on
trade entries. So, I'm just going to
quickly show you a trade I took a while
ago where, you know, it's basically the
same just to kind of give a quick
overview of what we're trying to
accomplish again. We The first week we
were really starting on identifying just
these trends. And then I think this week
we can start to really focus on how do
we tell like when something is going to
actually bottom and that we can look for
an actual trade and reverse to the
upside. Especially this last week and
we'll get to it, there was a lot of
times where we got to, let's say like a
support level here or resistance level
up here and the market just broke those
levels. And so, how do you tell the
difference between that and the market
so showing signals where it's going to
start to reverse and we can enter in a
trade and, you know, take advantage of
that and and bet on the reversal. And
so, the big The big part about this
strategy is finding those reversal spots
here using, you know, the idea of
identifying the major trend of the
unhealthy trend into this support zone.
And then like in this trade, identifying
there's a head and shoulders pattern and
then a potential for the market to give
back this kind of unhealthy move. This
is a very common like target to go back
to this high right here. And so, this
weekend I think it makes sense to try
and get you ready to trade and not
necessarily be entering in, but focusing
on starting to identify them and have
the tools in place to figure out, okay,
how you can pull the trigger on these
trades and starting to paint the full
picture of, okay, the five-step process
to, you know, entering on this trade and
then, you know, what it looks like so we
can start to kind of visualize that
more. Perfect. What else? Yeah, and I
think last week we did a good big
picture of talking about identifying
trends and the big picture. I think it
makes more sense to, well, now we can
start to look at, I mean, head and
shoulders patterns and other patterns
that are used to enter in on. Yeah, I
had a couple spots where I was like,
seems like there could be something
here, but I don't really know what I'm
actually looking for in terms of an
entry. Yeah, and like when it pattern or
signal. How do you know when it's going
to continue going in one direction
versus
Yeah.
actually setting up a trade to reverse.
So, how normal the week was last week?
It definitely was not super normal.
Like, if I mean, even if you just look
at like a daily chart, you zoom all the
way in, let's see. We're technically on
Monday. So, if we discount this
candlestick, I mean, like the the wicks
were pretty big. I guess these are the
five candles of last week. Yeah.
>> definitely like pretty all over the
place, but you can also say like right
now that is kind of almost the norm.
Like, in the last few months there
definitely have been There's been times
where it's like, okay, a week you barely
move anything. Yeah. If these are, you
know, each of these are a daily chart
and then like you have like here's a
week where it's like, okay, the market
kind of went crazy. So, it's definitely
been like very volatile. And that's
where like, I don't know, market type
comes into or like just what the mode
the market is cuz if you, you know, look
at these last 4 months, but then you go
and look at, you know, the the four
months before them, like the amount of
movement that was happening was very
small. Just much smaller candlesticks.
>> And then there was some moves and then
some downs. So, like we're definitely in
a like much more volatile time. Okay.
Yeah, one of the I mean, one of my
questions farther down was like, how do
you determine if a candlestick is like
big or significant in terms of sizing?
And like is there like a number of
little What are they called on the side?
Points?
>> Ticks or points?
>> Ticks. Yeah, ticks or points that like
it needs to hit for it to be like, "Oh,
that's a significant move. Like that's I
don't know, indicating that the market's
moving heavily in one direction. I
should enter in a trade." Or is that
kind of all just relative to what the
market's been doing? And so for
instance, like just like you were saying
here, everything's been going up and
down like crazy. Yeah.
>> So, that's kind of just normal day or
normal week. I mean, I think it's like
even day-to-day it can change. You know,
you judge a
>> Yeah. Yeah. Like Is this all kind of
relative? Yeah, I mean, like, you know,
you have candles like this where it's
like they're kind of this size and then
all of a sudden like they're this size
and then all of a sudden, you know,
they're this size. And so I think it's
like just kind of using, "Okay, what has
the market done in the past recently?
And where you like what are the current
candles being printed in relation to
that?" So, like this candlestick is
huge. Yeah. Compared to these ones.
That's what I meant to say. That, you
know, just knowing that, okay, something
something has changed and this is like
something you should pay attention to.
Um and know that like a lot of time that
can change what's going on in the market
and then also even like a big
candlestick like this in a choppy
situation like this, it's it can be a
lot more likely that it just reverses
like it did right here. I think we
briefly touched about it, but like even
something like that, even though it
seems like, "Oh, it's so unhealthy. It
has to snap back." Like if there's not
really an entry spot or something
obvious, it's just not worth trying to
take it cuz you're just essentially
FOMOing in. Yeah, I mean, those like V
bottoms like that are just really hard
to They're just not tradeable. Yeah,
it's more like gambling then. Yeah, I
mean, sometimes like when the I mean,
even like on this day last week, I think
this was Wednesday or something. But,
you know, where the market just like
opened up here and just sold off for
hours. Yeah. Trying to like catch a
bottom when the market's so strong in
one direction just doesn't really work
cuz it's just so unlikely to reverse
after it it starts to really move in one
direction with that like momentum. Yeah.
Yeah, there's just so much pressure.
Okay. Yeah, I guess I think I think it
was on the day before this, on the 27th,
there was a lot of upward pressure. And
one of the things like you traded for a
bit and then in Discord were just like,
"Going to be really hard to take a trade
today." It's just Yeah. Yeah, just
really hard Going to be really hard to
take a trade today. And it seemed like
it was hitting some, I guess, resistance
levels throughout the day. But, maybe
it's just like there's just Was there
just kind of like too much upward
pressure that even if it hits resistance
levels, it's just so likely to continue
going up? Was this This is the 27th? E
Okay, yeah. Yes, yeah. 127. I was trying
to situate myself on the chart. Yeah,
but I think looking at it, trying to
just find the price of what it looked
like before the market opened, I think
the idea was that with this was that we
just taking into account like the super
big picture of having this big sell-off
and bottom the week before. And then it
kind of did this consolidation pattern
like bull flag or, you know, pullback
where the market just kind of chopped
for a few days and then it breaking out
of that.
>> Yeah. And then pulling back and
continuing higher, it just seemed like
there was a really strong trend in
place, so it was more likely to just
continue higher.
>> Okay. And even though like there's these
highs back here, you know, you can
definitely make a good resistance zone
off of this. Yeah, that's one of the
ones I drew. E- even if you pull it down
to like where these two highs touch,
too. Like it's very far away from the
open price. And so it just seemed like
it would be more likely that the market
would just, you know, trend higher over
the day. And so like going on to
1-minute chart, I think this is that
level. Like when it broke that
>> Yeah. And that's kind of where I was
looking. I was like, "Oh, is this a spot
where it could reverse now?" Cuz you've
you've hit your resistance level and it
looks like it's doing almost like a
little double bounce or testing if it's
wants to fail. But also it has maybe
it's just a question of like has so much
momentum behind it heading upwards that
it's probably just going to continue
upwards through an old resistance level.
I mean same thing though. Like both of
them on this day, the Nasdaq pretty much
opened at the resistance level and then
sold off and came up. And so I mean both
of them kind of hitting that move up in
the morning. Like this was a a nice move
into that level like to where it could
reverse. Yeah. But one thing was when
the market it opened here and when it
kind of does that spike lower first and
then it's almost like think about it
like the market's already faked in one
direction this morning. And so Probably
not going to do it again. Yeah. I mean a
lot of like you have multiple ways the
market can play out in the day and I
feel like a lot of times it'll One
option is it fakes in one direction and
then trends in the opposite way it faked
or it could just start faking in every
direction and you have more of a range
bound day and choppy day. But a lot of
the times, especially if you know, you
take into account the big picture of
thinking that overall there's going to
be upwards pressure, it's more likely
that this fake lower is going to turn
into just trading higher. So even though
it comes up Yeah.
and had this like big bearish bar, you
know, you can start to think, "Okay,
well that could turn into a spot where I
could look for a reversal." Cuz this
could be considered a pretty rapid
unhealthy trend move, you know, cuz all
the There's just bullish candlesticks
here. Yeah. But, I think the big thing
is, okay, well, if it Trying to think of
like where the market's going to move is
where like the gaps between like support
and resistance. And And And so, like
where is this going to pull back to? And
you can't just think about the low here.
You have to think about, okay, well,
there's kind of this here, too. Yeah.
>> And so, it's It could come back to here.
It could be breaking out and pulling
back to this these previous highs from
like
>> Ah, yeah. the overnight high. So,
there's all this price movement in here,
which makes it so there's not as much
of, you know, when you think about like
the fair value gap idea of like if
there's just nothing to hold the market,
it'll just fill that quickly. Like I'm
trying to find a good example here. Even
like this is a good example of like,
okay, the market shoots up here, and
there's so much room between here and,
you know, this previous swing here for
it to like move down.
>> Mhm.
>> And so, the potential [clears throat]
for a swing to go long ways is higher,
cuz there's not as much support or in a
way. And like you kind of you could draw
this here, but really it's like so close
that it's hard to fill or break out of
that.
>> Yeah. Yeah, so it's like the next level
down. Um that's why I like I won't take,
you know, even though this looks good,
sometimes I'll think, okay, well, if I
enter in here, how much space do I have
before it runs into some resistance? And
in the sense of like, you know, if
you're getting in a trade and you're,
you know, your risk reward is like this,
it's like, okay, well, it's It doesn't
go very far in my favor before it, you
know, has a chance to reverse. And so,
that's a big thing to think about, I
think, when understanding like like a
almost like a little bit advanced of
like understanding when it's worth
risking taking a trade is is those gaps,
but I also think that just comes with
reading the trends as well of like and
in a way like the help a healthy or
unhealthy move potential. Yeah. And I
think like here, like the patterns I
would be looking to short here cuz just
because this is here doesn't mean it's
like not a good spot to bid a trade. I
think here like this can actually be a
good signal too of like, oh, you know,
this thing moved up. Clearly it was
losing steam right here cuz it got super
choppy.
>> Yeah. And then all of a sudden it just,
you know, broke lower in a big way. And
so because but so with that, you know,
my first thought is like, okay, well, is
this just a pullback to continue higher,
you know, cuz it's the pullback of the
like that is healthy in the sense of for
the uptrend. And so I would want to see,
okay, what is this What is What is like
these next three candlesticks look like?
Does it, you know, start to come up and
like retest this area where it failed
and then start to turn down? That's
where you would start to want to think
about, okay, well, then maybe I'll get
in short once it like breaks this low
again. Goes through that, yeah. Cuz the
way I see that is like it's it's really
telling it's showing you that this is
like a, you know, I don't like to read
into every individual candlestick, but I
think in these key areas it really helps
to. Yeah. And so that's where like I
would be reading into the candlesticks
and looking at it like, okay, how is the
price reacting to and is it going to
make a new high? And if it breaks and
makes new high, I think it's probably
just going to keep continuing higher cuz
that's a really strong signal. Yeah,
strong rejection of that. Yeah, of this
like failure to or trap to go lower or,
you know, attempt to go lower. And then
this becomes an attempt to go higher and
it succeeds by making a new high versus
attempting to go higher and then
failing. And so, you know, even for like
almost like for this big candlestick,
it's almost like any whichever way it
breaks out is a big signal. Okay. If it
broke that that way or broke out this
way, but like this isn't I I don't
consider this candlestick, you know,
breaking out of this. Like I think
that's that's almost just like, okay,
it's moving down really fast. The
candlestick closes in a couple seconds,
continue, and then it reverses. You
know, you just see it as one move. Yeah.
Yeah, that was something I was thinking
about for either like 5 or 15-minute
candlesticks is that to some extent how
they're drawn very much depends on which
minutes of market activity they
encompass. And if you move them 30
seconds or 1 minute the other like
either direction, it can change the
shape dramatically. Yeah, that's why I
think Yes, I mean that's a really good
observation is Yeah, like the
candlestick forms very differently if
you just change the time by a couple
seconds. And so, I Some people would do
this and I don't think this is good.
Some people would just go to like, oh,
if they don't like how the 1-minute
chart will look or confirms, they'll go
to, you know, a 2-minute chart. Or like,
you know, they'll go to like a 30-second
chart. And it's like it changes how the
candlesticks look, but again, like in a
lot of ways you're just almost like
trying to find something that looks good
to you. You're trying to find something
that says yes. Yeah, you're you're like
basically looking for a confirmation.
And you know, with how the market is,
it's you can always find that if you set
the right indicator or thing on your
screen, you know. You could You could
just draw something that tells you, you
know, to go short. You could just make
some random pattern up. Riley, I've got
a new indicator for you. Whenever
there's a white candlestick, you enter.
>> [laughter]
>> How do you How do you look at it when it
You just scroll a little bit to the
right. When it's comes back and
re-touches
at the I don't know, what is it?
10:30-ish time frame?
Right in there.
>> area? Like it Yeah, when it re-touches
that, are you thinking about like, oh,
is this a
I don't know, that's not really head and
shoulders for but like is that another
spot where it's testing downward
pressure to see if this whole thing is a
failed breakout or like I don't I guess
the question is like what constitutes a
failed breakout and what does its like
time frame look like of like Yeah. I
generally think they have to happen
pretty quickly. Okay. Just because I
think the idea with them is you know the
movements happening quickly and then you
know it it some like double top like
this happens and then it fails like that
with cuz the idea is it's a lot of
people getting in rapidly getting super
excited and then there's no actual
strength behind the market to hold this
price up and so the longer the market
sits up here the more strength there is
and confirmation that there's people
People are holding with them.
>> Yeah, they're accepting the price.
Either they're holding in you know they
bought down here and they think it's
going to continue higher so they're
holding or there's people jumping in
here or thinking it's still good. Either
way like it's not it it should happen
pretty quickly and again that's not
super you know super clear on like oh
wait this many candlesticks or wait this
many candlesticks.
>> Yeah. After this many candlesticks cuz
like here it's like this is still like I
don't know what 5 10 candlesticks and I
would still say yeah this could totally
happen have come up here and fail. But I
think it should be Yeah.
>> Okay if you know this was a strong for
this you know particular spot like this
is a big candlestick and in my eyes if
this candlestick if it doesn't come up
here and fail and and that's what
happens that's where it should have in
my eyes that's where it should have
happened and so if it makes a new high
and then starts to chop and even starts
to pull back I think at that point
>> Okay.
the failure
potential has gone and instead it's it's
transformed into it It be a different
kind of trade like even if it came up
here and and eventually slowly reverse
and trend down, it would be more likely
that it's a slow sell-off. And those
aren't really like something I want to
play with just cuz they're a lot harder
to actually trade and manage. And in
that sense of like, you could also paint
the picture of well, this is just like a
bullish consolidation after that move.
So, it's hard to predict that you know,
I think Like, if you look at that on a
5-minute, it probably just looks exactly
like that. Yeah, and I think that you're
at this point you're you know, usually
these play out with the major trend. And
I would say the major trend is to the
upside. And so, you're betting on I
think at that point you're betting
against the major trend, um which isn't
a good idea. Yeah, I think a major the
major thing for me to try and focus on
next week is thinking about time frame
of everything and like making sure I'm
zooming out or using a good frame of
reference. Cuz like as you say here,
like if you paint the giant flag there,
yeah. And yeah, it's just like, "Oh,
this is just a consolidation." But
remembering to do that rather than
getting focused on, "Oh, in this tiny
window of time in this what hour and a
half that we have here on screen." Yeah.
Things can look one way, but as soon as
you zoom out a little bit, you're like,
"Oh, actually Yeah, it's more like
>> a consolidation. Yeah. And yeah, in a
huge uptrend. Yeah. Yeah, keeping the
bigger picture in mind is something for
me to work on or focus on. Yeah, and I
you know, like we talked about this last
week of I think that's the biggest thing
that'll be the key to your success
because you know, you can have all these
little like a great move up, you know,
these little micro patterns that look
good, but the micro patterns I think are
so inaccurate by themselves that they're
never were you know, they have to be
like the last thing that you think that
you're using. Yeah, they have to be
taken in context of Yeah.
>> the larger market and larger trends.
Yeah, you can't just go to a random spot
on the chart and, you know, enter in
based on that pattern and then win
money, you know. Yeah. How does like
weekend trading or after hours trading
work? And then like how much of a reset
is the weekend in terms of like market
behavior? Or is it kind of just not
really much of a reset cuz things kind
of are just always trading. I would say
sometimes it's a reset, but not every
time for sure. Cuz like if you look at
if I pull up more of a 15-minute chart.
If we look at, you know, like trying to
let's see Sunday,
last couple weekends are 31 and 24. So
like this was a weekend, this was a
weekend. You know what I mean? I think
it's generally it doesn't necessarily
reset it, but I do like to come into
Monday and see how things are going and
seeing a potential for movement
difference. But also I think a lot of
times like you're saying because trading
happens not 24/7, but pretty damn close.
Yeah.
>> And even when the market closes for the
weekend, it does close from, you know,
Friday at 4:00 Eastern time or 5:00 at
Eastern time and then opens up at 6:00
p.m. Sunday. And so it is closed for
like two days, but you know, here unless
something huge happens over the weekend,
like this just looks like normal. Like
that's Yeah.
>> look like anything happened here. And
then before the market even opens, I
mean the market then opens up here on
Monday. It There was a lot that happened
between now and then and I think it
allows you to just look at that data and
kind of see what's going on. But of
course like that doesn't mean Monday
could open up and a lot of things could
change. Yeah. So I think Monday is
definitely more of a day than the others
to be aware of potential
>> Potential for trend changes or swing
changes. Yeah. But even like today it
was, you know, I it seemed pretty
obvious that once the market kind of
opened up and started ripping higher
that we were just going to continue
higher for a while. Yeah. Just because,
you know, taking into account that big
picture of well, we had this huge V
bottom from Friday and then, you know,
Sunday night until Monday morning and
then opening up and and having that rip
higher. Heading higher and then Just
cuz, you know, yeah, it it it it was
pretty overextended. Yeah. Cuz what?
Professional traders aren't trading on
the weekend. They're only trading during
Yeah, I mean, like big banks and stuff.
Yeah, they're pretty much only trading
during main market hours. Okay. Okay, so
I
reading into it or coming up with an
explanation
that works or for myself would be like,
okay, yeah, non-professional traders or
casual traders traded over the weekend,
had a V bottom, and then Monday came in
and professional traders are like, yep,
we're ready to continue higher and then
just ripped it higher. Yeah, I mean,
Could just be a story that fits the
trend and then absolute but Yeah, and
it's also like just cuz well, the US
markets are closed, but like the other
Like I just mean wouldn't discount this
data of like being like, oh, just
because like main US banks aren't
trading US shares and stocks, doesn't
mean like that this isn't a reasonable
move that like has meaning behind it cuz
they're quite often it's like it it's
it's matching major moves happening in
other markets that are open like Asia or
Australia or Europe. So, I I just I just
view it as continuous data. Like I, you
know, cuz when I'm drawing levels, I
look at, okay, here's the most recent
swing low and here is a, you know, a
swing high that it had before it had
this sell-off. So, like if we're coming
up here, like that was my initial target
of like, okay, well, this is going to be
an interesting spot to look for if it
reverses. Um, and also, you know, that's
where the market closed on Friday and we
had this kind of gap down. Um, and then
after that, you know, it's there's not
really a good These little swings, like
as the market's making these little
swings down, I don't really like to just
be like, "Okay, well, I'm going to, you
know, make a level here, make a level
here." You know, you can't keep track of
all these again, like the whole idea
with looking at levels and zones is
trying to identify the more significant
ones. And
>> Yeah. the reason why this one is
significant over these other four is
because this is where this sell-off
basically started. Um and so that's
where I would assume that, you know, the
whole idea of, "Okay, when a market has
a big sell-off, it's going to fill that
and give that back up." And it could
then sell off again. And then also
>> equilibrium. Yeah, and then this is also
where the market closed on Friday. Um
and then gapped down. And so that's kind
of like just another significant area to
look at. Okay. Yeah, I had I had a
question on how you drew that level as
well as the one at the bottom. Is the
one at the bottom just because that's
your most recent significant low? Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, it's, you know, it's like
we bottomed here and then bottomed here.
And then but yeah, the main thing is
like, "Okay, well, if we get down there,
I want to see how the market reacts to
the most significant recent low." You
know, like I guess you could zoom out
and and, you know, if you have to go
pretty far back to find a new one. And
there is ones further down, but the most
recent ones are more likely to have
reactions than, you know, ones where you
have to zoom like, you know, weeks out
to find them, you know, where it's like,
"Okay, this one's 10 days old."
>> Yeah, I had I was trying to figure out
or I guess I had a question as well as
like, how do you view the strength of
like floors or resistance zones that
are, I don't know, um 2 days old, a week
old, a month old? And I guess it just
gets weaker the farther back they go,
but like do they just become irrelevant
or something is still kind of there? Is
I guess I guess maybe also question is
kind of like what's a speed bump versus
a a zone? I would say, yeah, it's like
like you initially said, as they are
farther and farther away the levels in
terms of like okay, 10 days old, you
know, 30 days old, 2 months old, you
know, if you kept zooming back. Yeah.
>> Um I don't consider those to be levels
after a while. Yeah, like that top one
you have there. That's I think the one I
was one of the ones I was kind of
primarily thinking about. Yeah, so one
first idea is I want to see how it's
going to hit that level because it's so
it's been so long that it's you know,
for a far back level that you drew it's
drawn it's been so long since the
market's even been at that price. A lot
could have changed and so I want to I'm
not going to initially think that it's
going to respect it because I don't know
any recent market action around that
level. Yeah, it's like the underlying
variables are constantly changing. And
so what happened? What is that? 2 weeks
ago or a month ago? 15 days from here to
here, yeah. Yeah, I mean well well now
so the other
argument is well, okay, we came up and
tested this level, sold off and then the
market's you know, regained strength and
now it's you know, coming to test it
again with probably more strength and so
it makes it more likely to break through
it. Mhm, essentially a giant V. Yeah,
like this is just a big, you know, if we
you know, zoom out even more to even
just a daily, it's like this level, you
know, it's just a swing a swing in the
market of like it just come here and
pulled back and now it's pushing
through. Yeah. So it's like I yeah.
>> you view that as like okay, maybe
something happens here or like it is a
it is a point to pay attention to but
unlikely to influence the market?
>> yeah, like with a big far level like
that, you know, it's like you have your
levels like that are really really solid
where it's like, you know, like this
when this level was originally made and
you know, you had it like this, and the
market was more looking like this. It's
like these were times where it was
really the level was really strong, and
you're more likely to Yeah. things in
the markets are going to respect it and
more aggressively trade at it versus
um
when it's coming here, you know, you
think, "Okay, the level's probably
weaker, but it's definitely a point of
interest." And so, how I would approach
that is, "Okay, well, if you know, let's
say if you know, you go down to a
1-minute chart, and the you know, the
level's all the way like up here or
something, and the market makes some
crazy move, and you say, "Well, okay,
the today the market trend into this
level is really overextended, and
there's a ton of signals showing me that
I think that we're going to double top,
and we're going to sell off and give
this short-term move back up that we've
done." Yeah. Then it's it's worth, you
know, I would still take the trade
because there's still that area where it
has the potential, and then all these
other, you know, smaller trend signals
are giving you a big picture reason to
bet that the market's going to go down
there. Okay. Talking about resistance
zones, could you zoom back to that
screen you just had up or time frame?
So, looking at the like, I don't know,
22nd to 25th, how there's Yeah, there's
kind of a resistance zone through those
top little ones. Yeah, here? Yeah, right
through there. How do you I cuz I think
that's when I drew it at some point. How
do you or off the bottom of that maybe?
But how do you think of a zone when it's
like it kind of seems like there's
something there, but you also have
candlesticks or little sections that go
through it? Like here?
>> kind of Yeah, like does that discount
that kind of resistance zone, or cuz it
there's something still a little bit
there, and it's I think it can, yeah.
It's a small indicator to pay attention
to, but not a strong It's like a It's a
little bit of a zone, but it's not a
strong zone. Yeah, I mean, like I would
say this is like it did, basically did a
failed breakout, you know, whatever this
like this is, you know, I'm looking at
the time at the bottom like, you know,
it's the market's open right here and so
it did some kind of punch higher then
failed back in.
Um,
but it definitely like I think makes it
so this resistance level is a little
more tricky like more like than likely I
wouldn't be looking for like it to come
up here again. I would think, "Okay,
well, maybe I start tracking this high
now." Cuz a lot of times when levels
start to get broken like this, it's
like, "Okay, something's going to start
changing and it's either going to
Sometimes it'll break out this way then
fail and then push out the other end."
Uh, or it could be like it's breaking
and then comes back and then breaks it
again and actually like that's where it
finds the actual strength to continue
higher without failing back in. Yeah.
Um, looking at the bottom one for those.
Uh, yeah, that one there. Yeah, I did
something where I kind of pulled that
pretty far across um, for looking for
when this whole thing kind of comes back
down. Yeah, through there.
And it seemed like it kind of worked but
it was also felt like something where I
was just Yeah, it kind of It seemed like
it kind of worked but also something
where I was kind of just like hunting
for something. Is that like Um, no, I
mean, I think that
>> enough or
>> [laughter]
>> I No, I think it's a good like my
assumption with this move up and then if
it when it started to really like rip
like this Yeah, lose its 2%. This move
like if the idea of it it's going to
give this whole move back up, I would
think that it would somehow come to this
zone and find support. It doesn't have
to necessarily be this support level,
but I would think
>> to view it as a bigger zone.
>> Yeah, like this is where the market was
chopping and gaining strength and then
just took off and then it, you know, it
failed and so like that's, you know,
where I kind of just, you know, with the
idea of, "Okay, it's going to give the
whole swing back up." If it fails,
that's how I would read that. So, that
did kind of essentially align up with
that perfectly.
So, I yeah, I mean I think that that's a
good level and target to be looking for
that. I mean like during it I'd be
>> thought Yeah, I mean like I'd probably
just be thinking like, "Okay, it's going
to come out down here somewhere." Yeah.
And then you know, you'd go into smaller
time frame and look at when it actually
bottoms. Yeah. But even Yeah, I guess
and then leads into the next question of
like, when it rips down like that, how
do you how do you even I mean it maybe
it's something where it's like, yeah, I
know you just don't really think about
taking a trade in there because it's
moving has so much momentum and it is
moving so much in one direction. Like,
okay, it's in a little bit of a zone.
It's making a little bit of a I don't
know, tiny bounce or mini pullback or
whatever. Like, are you are you looking
of like, oh hey, maybe there's something
here or is it just there's so much
momentum and so much downward pressure?
Yeah, I guess I guess it's somewhat of
like the how do you determine the
balance between what is unhealthy
overextension and what is just a lot of
downward pressure cuz it like in the
15-minute chart it's just like two or
three candlesticks that are ripped down
through this. But like
on the one-minute chart you see a lot of
those like little tiny pullbacks or like
mini consolidations. Yeah. Yeah, so
there you like yeah, like that. Yeah,
this is a 5-minute and then yeah, here's
the 1-minute. Yeah. Um
Yeah, with cuz this kind of move is like
this is something that doesn't happen
very often. Yes, it is irrelevant not
irrelevant to talk about, but Well, it's
just like it's yeah, it's like so you
know, sometimes you're like, oh well,
and this is a great example of the the
dream of what you could do with like if
you did somehow, you know, like you're
saying here is that it bottomed like
almost exactly at that area and oh, if
you went long, it's like you would have
caught like somehow, you know, you would
have caught like a huge move back up.
And I find it really hard to actually do
that
cuz like trying to determine okay yeah
like this is what's healthy versus
unhealthy and even in this trend there
are pull backs and like all these trends
are you know it's every trend is going
to eventually reverse in some way. They
can't continue forever. Um. But. But in
terms of like trying to figure out like
okay if they we have a huge move like
this you know that means well eventually
it's going to have a huge reversal you
know like even looking at a 15 minute
chart here it's like it did pretty much
give back you know until like the market
closed like it gave back like 80% of the
move before it eventually continued to
sell off further. Hindsight this is
definitely was an unhealthy move
and it did reverse like middle of the
actual trading day but I guess in terms
of trading it like well first off like
looking at you know like more my timings
of like thinking about reversing. Yeah.
Like the the early moves like when it
moves so much in the first 30 minutes
like this cuz here's like the first 30
minutes first 45 where it's like okay
this is how much it's moved in the first
10 minutes which is a huge amount it's
kind of hard to look you know I guess
that helps comparatively to normal
market movement.
>> [clears throat]
>> But zoomed in it's kind of hard to tell
cuz there's no nothing to tell against
but I always find like it's the
momentum's just way more likely to
continue lower
um and like you know something like this
where you think okay well here's the
final attempt to go lower and then we
got some bullish candlesticks here where
it's like could continue higher and then
you know you think okay well what if it
gives back this whole move. Is it
setting up some sort of head and
shoulders? Yeah like
it's you know it's easy to start to look
at those micro patterns again and get
too laser focused on them when again
like okay well the big down trend is
telling you that there's a ton of
momentum lower and a ton of momentum
like can just kind of defy like the
norms. 99% of your trading time is like
spent in more normal market conditions.
Like yes, they go back and forth from
like, you know, having like decent moves
in a day and like choppiness and then
like a spike and lower and trending
days. But like very infrequently do you
have times where the market just all of
a sudden just some news is behind it and
there's just some craziness. And so it's
I almost try and stay away from those
days because
>> It's not behaving in a normal pattern.
>> Yeah, and like what you're trying to do
over time is have your strategy that you
do every day and if the market doesn't
fit that, you move on and a lot of times
like the market doesn't This isn't the
market fitting that, you know, cuz it's
not making a like an unhealthy move down
that you think it's going to reverse.
It's making a an extreme momentum move
down that could be an unhealthy move,
but in my experience most of the them
will move down and then they'll have
they they can still have some big moves
up, but a lot of time they'll just go
into like a sideways chop or like a slow
bleed lower or maybe even like a slow
grind higher with some pullbacks that
are just like really hard to trade in.
And so I think trying to determine like
what's an unhealthy versus like a really
big momentum move just comes with kind
of experience of seeing the market. Like
this morning even, you know, like this
seemed like it could be an unhealthy
move Yeah. because the market just
opened up here, ripped up in the first
30 minutes and then, you know, had had
some chop here, had one more push higher
and then, you know, started to kind of
sell off here. And then it actually had
this candlestick where the market, you
know, went up and sold off in this one
candlestick here. And so, my thought was
like, "Oh, well, that looks like it
could be basically at the top."
>> And it could start to sell off and give
this move back up, cuz that really
aligns with, you know, my strategy of
seeing a move, hit a zone, happens in
the first 30 minutes. Um but, if it
just, you know, ripped up an even bigger
amount or just, you know, here it's that
signal didn't fully develop, it just
start continued higher. It's like,
"Okay, well, then it's there's just more
momentum behind it, and I'm just going
to move on with my day." Yeah. Yeah, I
think I watched it to about, what would
it be, 11 or so? Yeah, cuz then, I mean,
like even here, it's like big move up,
and then it just And this is why a lot
of time I don't I've stayed away from
being like, "Okay, well," and I've tried
it in the past like, "Okay, well, if
it's not going to If I don't think it's
going to reverse, well, why don't I bet
it's going to go higher?" And it's like
the hard part is a lot of times it's
like, "Well, a lot of the big move has
already happened." And so, you're
betting on a continuation of the this
trend becoming an even bigger trend.
Yeah. And like today is a perfect
example where it just went up and just
kind of sat there. Yeah, or it seems
like it's just going to [clears throat]
make a little flag. Like, we shot up,
and now it's consolidated over a small
period of space. Yeah, so I mean, that's
just like such a hard part about trading
is seeing all these different things in
the market and seeing thinking, "Okay,
how can I profit from this? And how can
I profit from that?" And in reality, you
know, that's trying to fit what the
market's doing versus waiting for the
market to fit what you want and just
Yeah. taking advantage of that, even if
it doesn't happen very often. Now, if
you still don't have a trading platform
to actually do this, we are using
NinjaTrader. It's probably the best
futures trading platform out there. You
can start with as little as $4, which is
a lot less than other platforms. And so,
you can get it in the link in the
description or this QR code. I highly
recommend it. I've been using it for
over 5 years at this point. One of the
questions I had from this morning, um
was around how the ES and NQ interact
with each other. Um, and so I think the
way it worked this morning is so that
resistance level or zone that you had
drawn there, um,
the ES hit it first and so I was like,
"Okay, if the um, essentially like,
okay, the ES hit this first, the ES
might reverse here. Would you expect to
take a trade on NQ if NQ was following
ES?" And then similarly, when NQ hit
that zone, would you expect, if ES has
just continued shooting upwards, would
you expect NQ to reverse or just kind of
keep following ES up through the zone?
Does that make sense? Mhm.
I think I need you to say that again.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
Uh, essentially it's just like
understanding more about how ES and NQ
interact and follow each other. And so
if one hits a support zone or a
resistance zone and the other's not at
that zone yet, do you expect the other
to potentially reverse if the first one
reverses? So for instance, if ES hits a
zone and reverses, do you expect NQ to
reverse wherever it is even if it's not
at a resistance zone? Okay, so yeah, I
think I understand your question. Like
how did things, how did ES and Nasdaq
correlate and when one's hitting a zone
and one's not, will the other one like
catch up first or will it just kind of
reverse where it is? Yeah, or or or in
some ways it's like if if one reverses,
do you expect a reversal in the other?
Okay, yeah. So I mean, I I think a lot
of it's how this kind of goes back to I
think my rule of like I need them to
both be trending the same way and acting
the same way, very similarly at least.
Like, you know, this morning it's like,
um, let me try and just get these charts
to like almost match perfectly. And
okay, so this is pretty much the same
point in time even though the chart
there's more space here.
Um
you know, the NASDAQ had these big
spikes and flags this morning where the
ES was almost more just kind of like
continuous chug higher, you know, maybe
you could say there's a little flag
here, little flag here, and then it had
that spike. Yeah.
But you know, that's without reading too
much into the candlesticks, like just at
a glance, okay, the trends are basically
the same. Like we're just
>> Yeah. opening and moving up.
Um and so I view those as Okay, they're
both correlated, they're both going to
be pretty much doing the same thing. You
know, one might make like like a little
bit of a divergence here was Okay, the
ES made a high here and it sold off like
this far where the NASDAQ made a high
here and sold off like just not as far.
Um
>> Yeah. And so, you know, it's like there
was a little bit of a divergence there
and the thought was like Okay, well, if
I take a short, will the ES sell off
faster and harder than the NASDAQ?
Um but both of them I think would sell
off even if like you're saying the
NASDAQ is at like a resistance zone and
there's this downtrend that I had drawn
this morning from my kind of the big
picture of these like swings. Okay,
we're coming up to this area, you know,
if we hit this, how does it kind of like
sell off when it if it is going to? Even
if the ES wasn't at that level, like I
would still think that Okay, the ES it
would sell off, too. I would say that it
makes it kind of less likely for it to
happen, though. I would say the better
setups and trades happen when both of
them are at a clear reversal zone. Okay,
at the same time essentially. Yeah, cuz
it's
>> Yeah, cuz that was part of my That was
part of my question this morning is that
it seemed to like the ES hit the
resistance zone while NQ was still like
in between resistance zones or hadn't
got to that same point in time. And then
it did later on and I think at that
point ES had continued through it. Mhm.
Yeah, I mean I think it's just another
one of those things of like trying to
have things line up really well, you
know, and that's when you, you know, you
bet on the outcome. Just cuz it's just
another variable where, you know, that
the quite opposite thing that I see
often is like, okay, the ES just opens
and sits there while the NASDAQ opens
and spikes in a direction. And so, you
know, I used to think, oh, well, if the
ES isn't moving, maybe it'll that shows
weakness in the market and the NASDAQ
will just give this move back up. Yeah.
And that doesn't have like it's just
it's a lot harder predict to predict
what's going to happen when they're not
moving together. Thinking about timings
in the market and you focus to be around
the most of the time specifically around
the 10:00 a.m. one. How like if it
doesn't reverse at 10:00 a.m. and kind
of just continues through that or
doesn't have a major change like around
that, do you expect that when it comes
to the 11:00 a.m. point that it's also
going to kind of just continue through
and follow what it's been doing or is
that another spot where it will No, I
think I think
>> for reversal. I think the 11:00 a.m. is
the other spot where you would say,
okay, even if it's been trending up
since the whole market open, if it, you
know, comes up to a resistance level and
the, you know, uptrend gets broken and
you see something like a double top or
something and you think that the trend
is has the potential to reverse, I think
11:00 is another window where you can
look for reversals. I don't think a lot
of time at that point it's not as much
of an unhealthy move that gets reversed
and it's not necessarily going to move
like very quickly versus like in the
morning the spikes up can be a lot
reversed a lot quicker if it's like at,
you know, the 9:45 time or the 10:00
time. So, like these moves can will be a
Get them. Okay, so it's a big move. It's
like the 7:00 a.m. was often going to be
more focused around an unhealthy move
while
7:00 a.m.
10:00 a.m. is going to be focused around
being an unhealthy move while the 11:00
a.m. is going to be more focused around
not structural but just like a more of a
shift in the market than something being
specifically unhealthy. This move right
here, I think you mentioned this earlier
like pretty much bottomed at 11:00.
Yeah. That day and so it's like pretty
much everything lined up there for it
was at that resistance reversal zone and
then this big move, you know, bottomed
around that time. Yeah. So, how do you
think about it when it gets into like
cuz I saw this I was like, okay, it's
done its it's done its two little
bottoms. It's then shot up for a little
bit. But then it kind of just yeah.
Well, then even before that like that
initial part and then it gets into that
chop and that was when I was like, okay,
it I could like it's just gone into chop
and consolidation and so now it seems
like it could just continue down or
continue up and then it obviously
continued up. Yeah, I mean, I think this
is it's basically like you're saying
like an inflection point like there's
it's I think it's a big decision spot of
like, okay, is it going to continue
lower and just be like a downtrend the
whole day cuz if you're looking at like,
you know, just this trend, it's like
it's basically coming up and testing
this previous swing low. Yeah. Yeah. Um
and so it's like, okay, in terms of a
stair step pattern, it could just it
could, you know, it had this big
aggressive trend and that clearly is
changing after this move up but that
doesn't mean like it's, you know, it
couldn't continue lower, right? It could
just be shifting from, okay, a huge
spike of a trend to like more of a
channel style trend. Yeah.
That's more of a broad trend. Yeah. And
so like but you know, that's where like
having that big resistance or support
zone comes into play of okay, well, that
maybe makes the odds of it breaking
through this a little bit better because
you think okay, well, that the overall
trend could shift because of that major
support zone. And then you know, you
could see this is a short-term like bull
flag as well. Yeah. So it's you know,
it's one of those spots where it's
tricky to to know exactly because it
could go a lot of this could go either
direction. You know, there's reasons to
support either especially because this
you know, trend was so aggressive and
had such momentum. Do you ever trade off
of those bull flags as a like indicator
to get in once you see that it starts
continuing higher or that point is it
just like a okay, it's continuing
higher. I can tell that but it's just
lost or you it's like potentially moved
significantly through whatever amount of
move it's going to make and then there's
just not necessarily enough room
[snorts] for the trade. Yeah, I mean for
my trades I like to be trying to target
getting in down here. Yeah. And once it
yeah, once it comes up here the thought
is like okay, well, a lot of the move is
already happened. Like the easy money
has happened. Yeah. And so it can get a
spot where it's like okay, well, why is
it doing this that you know, reduces
kind of the confidence in the potential
of the trade. Mhm, got it. Yeah, you're
limiting your upside. Okay. Have we
talked about setting levels at all when
things get super high? I guess maybe we
talked about like really briefly on the
phone of how do you trade when market
seems to be hitting all-time highs?
Yeah, like even let me bring up 15
minute chart.
>> Or monthly highs. Yeah, it's just like I
mean even sometimes like a lot of times
it's like oh, it's just making new
all-time highs. Like this where the
trend is just kind of like up and
there's no like every day it's just kind
of doing like this is continuing higher
and higher and there's nothing to look
back to the left side.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean, pretty much you're
just Sometimes I'll come in and I'll
look at Okay, well, if the market, you
know, opens up here, I'll think about
like Okay, well, there's this little
mini zone from overnight, and I'll see
Okay, well, what if the market comes up
here and and, you know, I look for a
bounce off of this zone. Or it can open
up like this where it's kind of like in
this chop range. This isn't a great
example, but it could be like doing like
this. Mhm.
>> And then if the range here is big
enough, I'll almost look to like trade
between this.
>> Trade in between it. Okay. Um otherwise,
Let's just Just kind of enjoy the show.
Yeah, I mean, otherwise, like it's just
like you just got to wait it out, you
know, it doesn't happen forever.
Eventually, you know, it's going to
start doing this and you can say Okay,
now here's a a zone and like here's a
zone and then trade in that and then,
you know, it shifts to this and then,
you know, it's just a part of always
adjusting to what's the market doing.
Yeah, and being patient. That seems like
a key. Yeah, I mean, it's like not every
market condition is going to work. You
know, no strategy can fit every market
condition. Yeah, and so don't force it.
Yeah. Yeah, you just want to all you
know, biggest thing is you want to just
try and be waiting for the market to
come to you, not going to the market.
Yeah. Shifting to talking about trend
lines a little bit more. How often are
you like redrawing them or adjusting
them? Seems like it'd be super easy to
do kind of really consistently. So, for
instance, like I don't know and that and
that large downward trend there. Like
this one
>> easy to draw. Yeah. Like it'd be easy to
draw one from Oh, I can't see the
bottom. What is that? 10 right there to
one of those highs a little bit lower
and then or draw it like before you know
the whole thing, putting it at the top
of that. Like it seems like it'd be
really easy to constantly kind of draw
them. And then like just keep adjusting.
Yeah. Yeah. And so kind of like what's
like the difference between like
adjusting versus a break through versus
just kind of a really poorly drawn trend
line. Like cuz you could have that one
there. I think I did this. Like I drew
one there and did that one to then to
that and then yeah. Like and you just
kind of end up with them. Yeah, you
could have them just all over the chart.
Everywhere. You know, it's it Of course
it always just ends up being kind of
subjective cuz it's a subjective thing
at the end of the day. Yeah. I try and
do it only like have them only if it's
like it's super clear that that is a
trend line. Like I think this one is
pretty dang clear because you have, you
know, here, here, here and then it
breaks. But that doesn't mean like
there'll be times where, you know, the
market there is this trend line and then
it starts to go into something like this
and you don't, you know, adjust and it
still this still fits or something.
Yeah. Like it could just be reasonably
well. Yeah. Yeah. And then, you know,
okay, you see this and it's like, okay,
well, I can now adjust to like something
like this taking into account these
three. But then, you know, it breaks
here. So I'm like, okay, well, I'm I'm
not going to I'm just going to discount
this cuz by the time the market comes
all the way back to this, it's most
likely, you know, it's just like a
support zone. It hasn't touched it in
forever and the trend is clearly like
changed and started to do something
different. I'm not going to expect it to
come up here and like start continuing
to respecting this downtrend. Like
that's not how it works. Yeah. Like they
usually stay in even even though it's
like you're doing a trend line quite
often the same thing you can still
basically do like a channel, you know,
and it's like, okay, it's respecting
like a channel and like you can match it
on like the other side or or somewhere,
you know.
>> Yeah. Um and once it kind of breaks
that, it's like, okay, well, it's
probably just going to not
>> It's not going to conform to that again
anymore. Yeah. Um
Okay. Yeah, I mean, same thing with like
this right here was like this morning we
kind of had like a channel and then it
broke that and so I'm like, "Okay, well,
I'm just going to delete these now cuz
it clearly this doesn't matter anymore,
you know, like the market's just
skyrocketed from there." Same thing with
like just on a 1-minute of like trying
to, you know, adjust to like, "Okay,
well, there's a some kind of trend here
or like did we a change and adjust to
like something like this?" I think a big
thing that threw throws people off and
threw me off in the beginning is it
doesn't have to be like at the major
swing or like the bottom of a swing. A
lot of the times a lot of the trends
will do what I call it's like a spike
and then trend. And so like it'll have
like a big move up and even it could be
all the way up here, it doesn't matter,
like it just makes a huge move and then
starts to go into something that's more
constructive. Yeah, that was I
ran into this literally this morning of
like, "Okay, do I draw there or do I
draw it off that bottom point where it's
makes the high spike and then actually
seems like it goes into Yeah.
>> a mini channel?" Goes like in Yeah, I I
mean like on these two charts like this
morning was I mean, there's not a good
trend line that fits this, to be honest.
Like it's this is just like a funky
weird like spike trend. And so it's like
you don't have to fit something and just
cuz there isn't a trend line, you can
also just be like, "Okay, well, even
though a trend line doesn't fit this, I
can tell that uh you know, here it's
like the trend is still in place cuz the
trend right now is spikes go sideways,
spike go sideways, spike go sideways, a
little bit of a pullback, but spike go
sideways and and so it's like you can
still tell like the market is still
doing the same thing and that's all
trends and trend lines are really
telling you is is the market
continuously doing what it's been doing
and which makes it more likely to
continue doing that, you know? Yeah. And
then once that breaks, then you're like,
"Okay, well, now it's over and I can
I'll expect something to change." Yeah.
Is there a time frame that's good to
draw trends over? I guess I found myself
um in a couple places drawing a a bunch
of like really small trend lines. It's
like, "Oh, there's a mini trend there or
there's a mini trend there." Like this?
Yeah. Yeah, or like someone something
almost like that. It's like, "Okay,
yeah, you can draw something there, but
is that is that even relevant at all to
what we're trying to do?" Right. Yeah,
yeah, I mean like you can just mark the
out of your chart if you really
want to. Um
>> Yeah. I Yeah, I don't think you want to
do that. I mean, I Even though it's like
you're looking at you know, you can look
at a 5-minute chart and a 15-minute
chart and you can look at a 1-minute
chart and those are like zooms in zoom
ins or zoom outs like that I'll look at
for cuz you can definitely see bigger
picture trends and stuff on those
different charts. You know, like with
this stuff, but I Same's kind of thing
with support and resistance levels. Like
I want to I only want to focus on the
main ones that are like really clear.
Yeah, the the ones that actually have
strength behind them. Yeah, and well,
and even like like here it's like,
"Okay, well, you can do you know, like
you were saying you can draw one like
here and here and here." It's like
instead of doing that like think about,
"Okay, what is the the more bigger
picture?" And that's you know, that like
trying to find some I mean, you know,
this isn't a good example, but like
looking at the main swings and saying,
"Okay, this is clearly like the trend
that it's in and then and I don't need
to draw little trend lines for each of
these spikes of the trend and then you
know, Yeah.
>> trend lines for the pullbacks of these
trends. Like you're just trying to you
know, at the end of the day all you're
trying to do with all this stuff is just
help you figure out like what the main
idea and main picture of what's going on
is. Um and you know, again like with the
philosophy of the big picture is
important and all these little micro
moves are really just a last minute
thing to confirm where you're going to
specifically enter in your your order.
Yeah, but really it's what is the big
picture? Yeah. Okay. Okay, that's a good
thing for me to work on for next week.
Oh, I guess we're assessing health in
the market. Like what chart are you
trying to do that on to some extent? Cuz
a lot of the time it's like if you look
at the 15-minute chart, it'll just be
steady blue upwards or steady blue
downwards or not blue, whatever your
colors are. But yeah, like steady up or
down.
>> Yeah, steady up or steady down. Um but
if you look at the 1-minute, it's got
little consolidations all over the
place. And like similar with 5-minutes,
like yeah, I guess it seems like it can
look unhealthy on one chart but be a
little bit more healthy on a smaller
time frame. And so are you is that like
are you assessing the health on a more a
larger time scale or more narrow time
scale? Yeah, I mean I look on a
1-minute, but like generally you can
it's easier to identify it on a
5-minute. Like especially if you use
like a fair value gap indicator that
just gives you, you know, like the
boxes. Yeah. Just to like really like
tell you, okay, here's where like the
overextended moves are.
Um
but like on a 1-minute,
>> Mhm.
you know, like you're saying like there
is the like Yeah, there's all of that.
Yeah, and so I guess part of my question
is like does that then not invalidate
what's happening on the 5- or 10-minute
or 5- or 15-minute chart?
>> consolidations.
Yeah. Yeah, or are they just they're
just small enough that they like don't
really matter? Yeah, I think it can be
small enough to where it doesn't matter.
Especially if you're looking for more of
like a 10-minute reversal or like an
11:00 11:00 reversal. Like on a big, you
know, the 5-minute like you can still
tell that it's overextended. Like even
like this, like looking at, you know,
the move we had today, like I would say
looking at this on a big picture,
5-minute like this is a pretty big move
that if it if it fails, like it'll
definitely come back down to here. Yeah.
You know, and even like on a 15-minute,
like like that's a big spike up that
totally could reverse. Like, you know,
of course like the it could just be a
bull flag and and continue higher. But
like the idea that it's there is
opportunity. Yeah, like going back to
what we talked about, like there's not
really that much between the you know,
the only previous swing is this. And so,
from you know, if it it it it would at
least come back down to here, I would
think, if it's going to give this back
up. And so, like there's a lot of
opportunity here of potential like I
guess void in the market for like it to
find support easily. Yeah. Um and so,
yeah, like you know, even though there's
this consolidation now, like it it still
can like, you know, even though it's
like, "Oh, I was I like to see it fail
right away." It can and will most likely
still have times where it does, you
know, maybe it just needs overnight to
happen. And then tomorrow it will
reverse. You know, stuff like that.
Like, you can always just zoom out to a
15-minute chart and it's like it's like
this move, too. Like, this move moved up
and and went sideways for a while and
then was given all the way back up.
Okay. I think that's at least all the
main questions I have, or at least has
given me plenty to think about. So,
Yeah, I mean, do you think it makes
sense to like like get you set up for
trading stuff? Or just still focus on
that? Maybe like put you could put the
fair value gap indicator on your chart.
And you know, you can just be thinking
about that stuff more and like thinking
about the five steps. I think Cuz that
was a lot and there's still like, you
know, just another week of legit trading
to be hopeful.
>> Like, yeah. Just looking and not pushing
it too much. Um I think putting the fair
value gap would be super useful, cuz
that just gives me a better idea of like
we got a little bit of idea of when
unhealthy is and stuff like that, but
having something to just I don't know,
help confirm it. Cuz a lot of my notes
on my chart are like, "Was this
unhealthy? Is that unhealthy? This seems
like it is."
Yeah, and so I think for that, like, you
can put it on put it like on the
5-minute, but then also you can also put
it on like the 50-minute. Yeah. Cuz the
50-minute is I think the 50-minute is
more clear of where the unhealthy moves
are. Now, sometimes the 50-minute isn't
enough for if you're catching like a 15-
or 30-minute reversal in the morning,
but big picture you'll be able to see
like Yeah, like this is, you know, this
is a great indicator that this is an
unhealthy move that we did this morning,
you know, and maybe we just come up to
this area and and sell off tomorrow and
and, you know, retest this low or or
something even. Yeah. How does that work
for For instance, if it if the market
opens tomorrow morning, I guess
obviously we have all the overnight
trading or after-hours trading, but if
it just starts going down immediately,
are you looking at stuff that's happened
before market open for it's like, "Oh,
yeah, there's a head and shoulder" or
it's already tested this
before market open and then starts going
down. Are you jumping in on it or are
you like, "Didn't hit my reversal" or
"Didn't hit my pattern at entry during
market open hours"? I would say I try
and stick to waiting the first 15
minutes
um to see that cuz a lot of times like I
have done times where I'll just Yeah,
for some like I think, "Oh, this is
doing a double top" and you know, I all
the signals are there and it's looks
like really good to sell off. Yeah.
>> Um and
>> But most of the time you're trying to
give it a little bit to figure out.
>> Yeah, and I I would rather see like it,
you know, spike up and attempt a new
high and maybe fail in the first 15 10
30 minutes and then enter in on that cuz
that's like a great signal to go short.
And personally, like, I just it feels a
lot more methodical and repeatable to do
it that way versus like there have been
times where I've caught like a a crazy
sell off like the market opens, you
know, and and and it just like sells off
right away.
Um
but those are those always kind of felt
a lot more of like trying to predict a
little bit more aggressively than
sticking to yeah, my like my strategy
and like what I I feel very confident
in. Got it. Okay. Well, do you want to
show me how to install the fair market
value? Yeah, I mean all you do is it's
in the NinjaTrader platform. So, you
just click this little I don't know. It
says indicators but it looks like a
little chart almost. Oh, you just search
for it. Yeah, you just type fair in here
and then you just double click it to add
it to the chart. What's max FVG? Just
how many that it will show. Like each
one of these is a fair value gap. And
so, you know, like if you scroll back,
it only it's only showing 40 I think on
mine and that might be the default. And
so, if you want more, you do more. Um
So, there's that the basic settings work
pretty good. It looks like the base is
It might be 10 but
>> 10. Yeah, I mean like I don't really
have a number. The main thing is like,
okay, I want to see the most recent
swing that I'm looking to see fail. Like
I don't really, you know, like looking
at a 15-minute chart like I don't really
need to see even though this big one
here still like technically is not
filled yet.
>> Yeah. Um
I'm not really looking to use that
anymore. Like I'm really looking to just
use this one.
>> It's another one of those things that's
just it's too far back. Yeah, and it
like it's going to eventually fill that
but like, you know, the main spike
reversal move has happened from that
one. Yeah. For the time frame that
you're looking to trade on, it's not
very relevant anymore. No, like if you
were yeah, like looking and you were
down here and you were looking to trade
over multiple days like then that's
something that's something else but
that's not what I'm doing. Yeah. Okay.
Cool. I got it installed. It sounds like
at this point this week just yeah, just
continue to focus on the trends and like
reading them and identifying what makes
sense that it does Yeah, like when you
think it hits these zones, like Yeah.
what makes sense that it does based on
the big picture. Cuz again, like that's
the biggest thing and then next week we
can get into like more the smaller
candlestick patterns for like head and
shoulders and like actually talk about
entering in trades and get that all set
up. Um okay. You know. I think that's
what I got. Thank you. This is
unbelievably helpful. That's all we got.
I don't know what [laughter] else to
say. I got it. All right. Bye. Love you.
Okay. Bye. Love you.
Now, if you're still new to a lot of
this and want to learn how futures work
and dive even deeper, check out this
video right here. It is an extremely
detailed tutorial that'll get you up to
speed even more.